mes amis je veux vous dire combien je
suis fier de prendre part à cette
journée historique de lancement de notre
mouvement les républicains moi qui suis
tout jeune en politique j'ai livré mon
premier combat électoral il ya seulement
deux ans pour les municipales à
montreuil montreuil vous savez cette
petite ville de la seine saint denis
dans le 93 maltraité par la gauche
depuis près de 70 ans
et bien moi je vais vous livrer mon
témoignage de l'élu de notre terre de
mission
les français nous attendent partout en
france et à commencer par montreuil
ils attendent l'alternance il a donc que
les républicains nous nous remontions
les manches pour redresser la france
cette journée de lancement de notre
mouvement est un grand moment solennel
parce qu'aujourd'hui nous nous engageons
devant les français à porter haut les
valeurs de la république
la transparence l'éthique le travail le
mérite l'éducation l'excellence que
françois hollande voudrait supprimer
pour niveau les tout le monde vers le
bas
mes amis l'arcor quête commence ici et
elle passe par les élections régionales
à venir
avec valérie pécresse les républicains
vont gagner la région ile de france
voilà je vous vous dire à tous je veux
dire à nicolas sarkozy et à tous ceux
qui ont contribué la création des
républicains que vous pouvez compter sur
moi
la petite élus de montreuil pour me
battre chaque jour sur le terrain pour
faire gagner nos idées et avec vous mes
amis
ensemble nous redresserons notre pays et
où les républicains
vive la seine saint denis et vive la
france